las vegas mayor carolyn goodman was  among the many leaders that celebrated  our city's history today the new  historic west side legacy park was  officially dedicated this afternoon it  serves as a tribute to the many  trailblazers who have led that community  through the years it includes the  stories of dozens of leaders that have  had a lasting impact on our city  it is wonderful  because they laid the groundwork and our  younger generation has to understand  this  you owe  the grandparents and the great pam  grandparents and everybody that's no  longer with us but maybe in a better  place but to make this community shine  like it never has before  nominations were for more honorees are  open now the public can submit names  online the 2022 honorees will be  announced in february